mes chers collègues nous avons donc
le grand plaisir et je conteneur de
recevoir cet après-midi
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire le ministre
l'Économie des Finances et la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
avec que nous pouvons
apprécier d'abord parce que c'est un des
principaux ministres du gouvernement
actuel mais aussi parce que il cogèrent
avec le ministère des infras étrangères
un certain nombre de responsabilités qui
concerne directement cette cette
commission monsieur le ministre je vous
souhaite mon cher Bruno je vous souhaite
la bienvenue dans cette commission
les sujets potentiels d'échange avec
vous ne manque pas nous soyons très
heureux de vous garder plusieurs heures
en prise d'otage par exemple mais et là
vous n'avez qu'une heure trente à nous
consacrer ce que je comprends très bien
et nous sommes nous convenus avec votre
cabinet
de nous concentrer sur l'actualité la
plus immédiate qui ne veut pas dire que
nous ne soyons pas preneurs de
discussion plus approfondie sur l'avenir
économique du pays sur
sa position internationale sur le plan
économique mais on peut pas tout faire
et donc je pense qu'on devrait se
consacrer à deux choses si vous en êtes
d'accord et je vais vous laisser parler
très vite c'est pas la peine que je
tienne
le crachoir c'est pas moi que nos
collègues sont venus entendre d'abord la
le sommet de la semaine dernière pour un
nouveau pacte financier mondial je
voudrais vraiment que vous nous disiez
ce que vous en tirez comme comme
conséquence c'est une initiative que
nous avons appréciée nous estimons moi
j'ai nous faisons un certain nombre de
déplacements il y avait effectivement
une très grande attente dans la
communauté internationale d'une
initiative de cet ordre puisque après
les résultats mitigés de la dernière COP
on avait quand même le sentiment que la
question centrale était celle de la mise
en place de financement permettant aux
états de qu'on qualifie maintenant de
Sud global de parvenir à dégager des
investissements qui leur permettent de
tenir leur leurs paroles leurs
engagements tenir la route tout
simplement dans la course à la
transition
à la transition énergétique et à la
réduction à au contrôle du climat
et puis deuxièmement nous sommes à
quelques jours de la Réunion tant
attendue ça a été l'arlésienne pendant
un temps infini du Sissi du comité
interministériel
et de la coopération internationale et
du développement
il semble une confirmerait qui s'est
réuni le 13 juillet qui se réunira
pardon le 13 juillet prochain et il fait
suite évidemment au Conseil de
développement qui s'est tenu à l'Elysée
alors sur ces deux ces deux grands
sujets je pense que vous avez vous avez
des choses à nous dire alors on vous a
expliqué la façon dont on procédé dans
cette commission pour éviter les pour
que ce soit vivant évidemment
notre invité c'est-à-dire vous
fait un effet fonte un exposé qui autour
de 15 minutes une dépasse pas 20 dont on
souhaite qu'il soit pas inférieur à 10
mais qui peut être à 15
et sur cette base les groupes
s'expriment chaque amende de un
représentant de chaque groupe s'exprime
sur deux minutes et demi mon problème
est en d'essayer de contenir mes
collègues en deux minutes et demi et
vous répondez dans le même format et là
mon problème c'est que ça serait
évidemment de contenir mon invité dans
le même format mais ça je n'y arrive
jamais
mais donc je fais appel à votre auto
régulation
voilà voilà comment ça se passe est-ce
que ce cette perspective à la fois ce
double agenda et les
procédures que nous que nous vous
proposons qui sont les nôtres vous
conviennent
parfaitement monsieur le Président en
revanche je vous présente pas parce que
ça ça serait à la fois inépuisable
inutile il n’épuisa parce que vos titres
vos talents sont innombrables
inutiles parce que nous les connaissons
tous
merci Monsieur de président
bourlange
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je suis très
heureux d'être devant votre commission
des affaires étrangères aujourd'hui pour
vous parler d'aide au développement et
de lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique je vais essayer d'être bref
dans mon introduction pour laisser toute
la place comme vous le souhaitez
monsieur le Président
aux questions et aux interrogations de
la commission le président de la
République comme vous le savez a fait de
cette aide au développement une priorité
depuis 2017 et je crois que le sommet
que nous avons eu la semaine dernière à
Paris on a été la meilleure illustration
quel est l'enjeu aujourd'hui de cette
aide publique au développement nous
avons l'enjeu traditionnel qui est de
permettre à des pays de franchir des
Caps en matière de développement
économique d'avoir accès à des biens
publics mondiaux d'améliorer leur
croissance et leur capacités à nourrir
leur population correctement alors
donner des emplois et de perspective de
développement
le deuxième enjeu il date du covid
le covid je le rappelle a été le choc
économique le plus dur depuis 1929
jamais depuis 1929 nous n'avons connu
des effondrements de production aussi
importants
mais il se trouve que au lendemain de
cette crise tous les pays développés ont
pu apporter une réponse économique parce
qu'ils en avaient les moyens budgétaires
ils ont consacré en moyenne un quart de
leur PNB au redressement économique et à
la relance là où les pays en
développement ne pouvaient consacrer que
2%. le deuxième enjeu qui est donc
nouveau c'est l'élargissement du fossé
ce que j'appelle la grande divergence
entre les pays développés les pays en
développement elle était en résorption
depuis 50 ans pour la première fois
depuis la crise du covid elle s'accroît
à nouveau
troisième enjeu le réchauffement
climatique chacun sait que le
réchauffement climatique touche d'abord
en priorité les pays du sud du continent
africain les pays du sud du continent
asiatique avec des incidents sur leur
niveau de développement
extraordinairement élevé autrement dit
jamais l'aide publique au développement
n'a été aussi nécessaire pour remédier à
ce risque de grande divergence et aux
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
et jamais elle a été aussi difficile à
financer puisque nous devons dans le
même temps rétablir nos finances
publiques et accélérer le désendettement
du pays l'enjeu est pour ces pays
l'enjeu est aussi national car il ne
faut se faire aucune illusion
renoncée à l'aide au développement c'est
accélérer le développement des flux
migratoires vers le continent européen
l'une des réponses de long terme qui
permettra d'éviter des flux migratoires
totalement incontrôlables à destination
de l'Europe c'est l'aide au
développement des pays sources
cela met du temps à donner des résultats
soient plus difficile soyez plus
exigeant mais cela me semble tout à fait
indispensable
le risque donc clair aujourd'hui celui
d'un décrochage définitif et
irréversible entre les pays développés
qui relancent sur l'économie et qui
profite à plein de la transition
climatique pour réindustrialiser leur
continent et leur nation c'est ce que
nous faisons en France pour la première
fois depuis 40 ans nous
réindustrialisons nous ouvrons des
usines nous créons des emplois
d'ouvriers nous créons des emplois
technologiques à forte valeur ajoutée et
les pays en développement qui cette fois
courraient le risque d'être
définitivement laissé de côté notre
conviction est donc que la solidarité
est indispensable mais qu'elle doit au
regard des contraintes de finance
publique prendre une forme nouvelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
organisé ce sommet pour un nouveau pacte
financier mondial l'objectif était de
commencer à définir les modalités de
cette nouvelle aide publique au
développement qui ne peut pas reposer
uniquement sur de l'argent public mais
qui doit reposer sur des mécanismes
différents plus efficaces et plus divers
nous sommes tous tombés d'accord avec
les participants à ce sommet sur le
constat le risque d'aggravation la
situation et nous avons commencé à
dessiner des pistes de solutions sur
lesquelles nous devons évidemment
aboutir à des résultats pratiques
première piste de réflexion c'est la
réorganisation des banques
multilatérales de développement pour que
leur engagement soit plus efficace et
donne de meilleurs résultats très
concrètement qu'est-ce que cela veut
dire il faut mieux utiliser le bilan de
ces banques aujourd'hui elles ne
prennent quasiment aucun risque pour
préserver à tout prix leur notation
triple A nous estimons qu'elles peuvent
conserver en adaptation triple A et
piocher davantage dans leur bilan
qu'elle ne le font aujourd'hui
deuxième orientation indispensable la
coopération entre ces banques l'idée que
chaque banque doit avoir son propre
projet et qu'il n'y a pas de
cofinancement entre les banques de
développement est une erreur nous
voulons que des projets à l'échelle d'un
continent où à l'échelle d'une région
puis cette portée par plusieurs banques
multilatérales de développement au lieu
d'avoir un fonctionnement aussi l'eau
qui est inefficace troisième réflexion
toujours sur les banques multilatérales
de développement il faut sortir de la
logique du drapeau national on ne fait
pas un projet pour le Mali pour le Niger
pour le Bénin on fait un projet pour une
région qui est touchée par un phénomène
de réchauffement climatique qui est une
incidence sur toute une région et qui ne
s'arrête pas à l'intérieur des
frontières au total nous estimons que la
meilleure utilisation du bilan des
banques et la coopération entre les
banques multilatérales de développement
de nous permettre de libérer 200
milliards de dollars de capacités de
financement additionnel sur 10
deuxième instrument que nous avons
proposé c'est le meilleur utilisation
des moyens du Fond Monétaire
International je pense en particulier
aux droits de tirage spéciaux qui comme
vous le savez sont promis pour les
villes pays vulnérables et qui doivent
aller à destination des pays les plus
menacés nous pouvons à ce titre dégager
100 milliards de dollars c'est ce que
nous avons annoncé lors du sommet la
France a engagé elle-même 20% de ses
droits de tirage spéciaux et l'envisage
de porter sa contribution à 40% nous
souhaitons que l'ensemble des pays
membres du FMI puisse porter le montant
de la contribution au titre des DTS à
30%. troisième voie de financement
nouvelle que nous avons proposé c'est la
possibilité de taxer au plan
international les émissions de CO2 des
compagnies régimes et de transport je
précise qu'il est pas question de mettre
en place une taxation nationale qui
toucherait une compagnie comme CMA CGM
faut pas vocation à alourdir la
fiscalité au niveau national sur une
entreprise qui est une entreprise qui
réussit remarquablement l'objectif est
que tout le monde soit logé à la même
enseigne et que cette taxation fasse
l'objet d'un consensus international
nous y sommes arrivés soit taxation des
gens du numérique nous y sommes arrivés
sur la taxation minimale à l'impôt sur
les sociétés nous voulons le faire
maintenant soit taxation des émissions
de CO2 des compagnies maritimes enfin
quatrième levier de financement
indispensable c'est la dette il est
évident que les pays les plus
vulnérables n'arriveront pas à se
redresser s'il n'y a pas des
restructuration de leur dette
souveraines cette structuration des
dettes souveraines se fait dans le cadre
du Club de Paris donne donc à la France
un rôle absolument majeur l'acteur
décisif pour parvenir un accord vous le
connaissez toutes et tous c'est la Chine
raison pour laquelle la présence du vice
du Premier ministre pardon chinois à
Paris était essentiel nous avons eu des
discussions avec le ministre chinois sur
la détermination de la Chine à
restructurer la dette des pays les plus
fragiles nous avons réussi à le faire
pour le Tchad nous avons réussi à le
faire pour la Zambie pour le Sri Lanka
pour le faire désormais pour un certain
nombre d'autres pays et il faut que la
Chine reste engagée dans cette
restructuration toujours sur la dette
nous avons proposé un mécanisme qui n'a
pas été définitivement adopté mais
paraît particulièrement pertinent c'est
de mettre en place une clause de
suspension du service de la dette en cas
d'événement climatique majeur si jamais
un pays est touché par une tornade par
une inondation par une période de
sécheresse particulièrement forte nous
pourrions prévoir que au lieu de
financer le service de sa dette il
suspend le service le paiement du
service de sa dette pour pouvoir réagir
à cette catastrophe climatique l'argent
nous semble mieux employés que de
financer le service de sa dette cette
cause de suspension me paraît
particulièrement
utile et prometteuse s'agissant de
l'échelle nationale vous savez tous ici
que la France est le quatrième plus gros
donateur mondial pour l'aide publique au
développement ça contribution est passée
de 10,1 milliards d'euros en 2017 à 15,1
milliards d'euros en 2022 c'est un
effort considérable qui témoigne de
notre engagement et de notre ambition
cette aide publique au développement
elle passe par le travail remarquable je
tiens à celui chacun de ces agents de
l'Agence française de développement qui
a atteint 12,3 milliards d'euros
d'engagement en 2022 avec 45% de son
activité concentré en Afrique sur des
projets qui sont des projets très
concrets utiles aux populations je pense
par exemple au TER de Dakar ou au métro
d'Abidjan mais là aussi comme pour
l'aide publique multilatérale il faut
que nous réfléchissions à de meilleurs
moyens d'orienter cette dépense et de
parvenir aux résultats les plus
efficaces
cette réflexion a été ouverte avec le
Conseil présidentiel pour le
développement mai dernier elle se
poursuivra avec le comité internat
extérieur de coopération internationale
et du développement et se traduira dans
un nouveau contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens pour laved il y a deux axes qui
me paraissent tout à fait essentiels
dans la réorganisation de cette aide au
développement d'abord nous devons
repenser le ciblage géographique et
concentrer les forces financiers de
l'État sur les pays les plus vulnérables
ceux qui sont consent confrontés pardon
à une situation d'extrême pauvreté en
deuxième lieu et c'est sans doute l'axe
qui est le plus novateur qui me paraît
le plus nécessaire il faut mieux
intégrer les financements privés car le
secteur public ne peut pas tout de la
même façon que je dis à l'échelle
nationale pour financer la transition
écologique nous ne pourrons pas financer
les 60 à 70 milliards d'euros qui seront
nécessaires chaque année uniquement par
de l'argent public sauf à augmenter
taxation des impôts ce que nous refusons
et qu'il faudra mobiliser davantage
l'épargne privée des Français et des
investissements privés de même à
l'échelle internationale il me paraît
indispensable de mobiliser davantage les
investisseurs privés je présenterai lors
de ce conseil un certain nombre
d'options pour délivrer ces financements
privés dans les meilleurs conditions
quant au ciblage géographique comme vous
le savez je l'ai indiqué précédemment la
France concentrente actuellement son
aide à 45% vers l'Afrique en particulier
vers 19 pays prioritaires les pays les
moins avancés je pense qu'il est
indispensable de continuer à concentrer
notre aide sur ces pays les moins
avancés en rajoutant aussi des critères
d'exposition aux etléas climatiques qui
sont essentielles pour l'avenir de ces
pays voilà très brièvement les quelques
éléments que je voulais vous présenter
aujourd'hui
je rajoute peut-être un point
conjoncturel mais qui est important
vous savez que nous avons aussi besoin
aujourd'hui d'apporter un soutien massif
à l'Ukraine que ce soutient à l'Ukraine
et décisif pour garantir la protection
de la souveraineté
ukrainienne et la défense du peuple
ukrainien ces sommes s'ajoutent aux
sommes que de dépensons au titre de
l'aide publique au développement raison
de plus pour que cette publique au
développement soit concentrée sur les
pays en situation d'extrême pauvreté
confronter les dérèglements climatiques
majeurs avec l'intérêt double de
répondre entre vos questions nationales
d'aider les pays en développement et les
plus fragiles et d'intérêt national
aussi de limiter les flux migratoires à
destination de l'Europe
merci cette exposé extrêmement claire
très roboratif
nous voyons la direction dans laquelle
on s'engage on n'est pas tout à fait sûr
que nous allons parvenir à atteindre
tous nos objectifs ça dépendra de
beaucoup de choses et de beaucoup
d'autres que nous mais ça le mérite en
tout cas de donner une ligne claire à
cette audition et maintenant ce sont nos
collègues qui vont vous adresser à vous
et pour commencer pour le groupe
Renaissance ce sera monsieur Adrien
Gomis mon cher Adrien c'est à vous merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues ce sommet pour
un nouveau pacte financier mondial
visait à poser les bases d'un système
financier international renouvelé créant
les conditions d'un choc de financement
pour qu'aucun pays né à choisir entre la
réduction de la pauvreté la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique et la
préservation de la biodiversité
au nom du groupe renaissant je tenais à
saluer les efforts qui sont les vôtres
monsieur le ministre et ceux du
président de la République qui ont
permis d'obtenir une série d'engagements
contribuant à réformer le système
financier international près de 80 ans
après la création des institutions de
Bretton-Woods
l'ambition de ce sommet de Paris était
clair permettre une opération de
solidarité financière vers les pays du
Sud pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
l'objectif est en partie atteint avec
l'engagement des pays les plus
développés à mobiliser 100 milliards de
dollars pour aider les pays les plus
vulnérables sous la forme de droite
tirage spéciaux
un autre enjeu majeur est de permettre
au pays les plus pauvres d'obtenir des
financements à faible coût dans ce cadre
la question de la dette est prégnante
elle est un fardeau trop lourd sur les
épaules des pays en situation d'extrême
pauvreté vous l'avez rappelé
précédemment la restructuration de leur
dette publique ne semble pas toujours
être une solution miracle dans le
contexte financier que nous connaissons
en revanche la création d'une clause
climat insérée dans la dette des pays
vulnérables à travers des prêts
bancaires est une solution d'avenir
collant aux réalités de notre époque ma
question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît
revenir sur cette clause climat ses
avantages et l'espoir qu'elle peut être
effective qu'elle puisse être effective
dans les prochaines années merci à vous
je vous remercie monsieur le député
monsieur le ministre
il vous a laissé pas mal de temps il n'a
pris qu'une minute 40
Adrien donc ça prouve que vous avez vous
à 45 secondes de plus que prévu
tangente et vous dépassez les trois
minutes
merci monsieur le Président cher Adrien
Gomy donc l'objectif c'est de créer une
clause de résilience climatique pour que
n'importe quel état confronté à un choc
climatique et qui fait partie évidemment
de la liste des pays soutenus par la FFD
puis suspendre jusqu'à 2 ans le
remboursement de sa dette quelle est
l'avantage la suspension du
remboursement dégage des marges de
mano-financière pour remédier à la crise
climatique et aux conséquences la crise
climatique des placements de population
problème de famine problème de sécurité
et en deuxième lieu elle évite le défaut
qui nuit à la crédibilité du pays un
pays qui est confronté à la réponse à la
crise climatique plus au service de sa
dette peut se retrouver en défaut ce qui
veut dire que à la sortie c'est taux
d'emprunt vont augmenter et devenir
insupportable nous sommes le premier
pays avoir mis en oeuvre cette clause
suspension du service de la dette nous
souhaitons que cette clause soit
généralisée au plus grand nombre de pays
dans les mois ou les années qui viennent
je peux poser une question dans le dans
le même genre dans la suite de celle de
Monsieur Gomi pourquoi pourquoi
uniquement le climat pourquoi pas la
pêche lui ou le ou le la pandémie que
nous faisons de traverser c'est c'est un
handicap aussi aussi profond aussi
perturbateurs pour les temps en question
pourquoi vous êtes vous limiter
au seul aux seuls qui m'a parce que pour
deux raisons la première c'est que notre
évaluation c'est que la première menace
qui paie sur les pays confrontés à une
situation de l'extrême pauvreté c'est le
climat les travaux d'Esther Duflot par
exemple ont montré que les coups pour
ces pays du changement climatique
pouvaient atteindre 500 milliards de
dollars par an de coûts supplémentaires
la deuxième raison c'est que si nous
voulons convaincre un certain nombre
d'États notamment du G7 et du G20 de
nous suivre je pense qu'il vaut mieux
avoir un champ d'application limité très
bien il faut tenir compte de la
parcimonie générale
pour le rassemblement national je pense
que c'est madame la députée du Nord
Madame Le Pen qui va qui va s'exprimer
du Pas-de-Calais pardon merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre le
sommet de Paris pour un nouveau pacte
financier des mondes que la France
demeure une grande puissance
diplomatique la France Libre généreuse
et goliène a toujours plaidé pour une
politique ambitieuse d'aide au
développement mais aussi pour que les
institutions internationales soient
adaptées aux nouvelles équilibre des
puissances seul un cadre juste et
respectueux des peuples permet que
l'argent prêtait et investi soit
vraiment efficace j'ai mon même porté
des propositions fortes de réforme de
l'ONU du FMI de la Banque mondiale lors
de la dernière présidentielle mais aussi
lors de mes rencontres avec des
dirigeants étrangers comme le président
du Sénégal Macky Sall
ces réformes doivent être guidées par le
principe que je considère comme premier
de respect de la souveraineté des
peuples au terme de ce sommet si les
annonces confirmées par Emmanuel Macron
sont parfois bienvenus l'essentiel
restait là très limité et décevant à
l'image de la politique de
co-développement menée par les pays
occidentaux cette dernière reste en 2022
de moitié inférieure aux promesses
faites depuis les années 70 et Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas réussi à mobiliser les
sommes promises depuis six ans y compris
à travers les droits de tirage spéciaux
du FMI avec la hausse des taux d'intérêt
beaucoup de pays en développement sont
littéralement pris à la gorge comme le
Ghana qui doit consacrer 70% de ses
ressources budgétaires au remboursement
de sa dette ces manquements évident
alors parole affaiblissent doucement et
sûrement le crédit des démocraties
auprès du reste du monde alors que le
co-développement est indispensable pour
gérer certains sujets comme
l'immigration bien sûr ou pour
contrebalancer la prédominance d'autres
pays comme la Chine
les Français aspirent à une politique
équilibrée juste et généreuse mais ils
veulent savoir si cet argent est bien
investi pour l'intérêt général et non le
bénéfice de quelques-uns ce sommet
démontre que la France est capable de
mener de grands combats diplomatiques
d'être une force d'entraînement et de
proposition aussi Monsieur le Ministre
la France ne doit-elle pas désormais
reprendre la main sur sa politique de
co-développement par rapport à la
Commission européenne mais aussi par
rapport à un certain nombre d'ONG au
parcours sinueux qui n’ont aucune forme
de légitimité je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre
merci et monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente Le Pen d'abord merci de
reconnaître que la voix de la France par
l'intermédiaire du président de la
République porte à l'étranger je vous
rejoins totalement sur ce point-là et je
crois que le sommet de Paris on a
apporté la démonstration je vous rejoins
aussi sur l'importance vitale pour la
nation française pour sa souveraineté
pour sa place dans le monde continuer à
défendre une politique de développement
ambitieuse nous avons obtenu des
résultats sur les DTS je vous rassure ce
point 100 milliards de dollars même si
je reconnais bien volontiers que nous
nous heurtons aussi à des difficultés de
politique intérieure de certains pays
j'en étais laid nous a indiqué de
manière très claire que les blocages du
Congrès américain du parti des
républicains empêchaient les États-Unis
d'aller aussi loin qu'il aurait voulu
sur la part de DTS qui serait réalloué
au pays en développement nous nous
continuons à pousser 30%. nous a
confirmé également que sur l'utilisation
des réserves d'or qui est une des
propositions que nous avons faites les
blocages au Congrès empêchaient
d'atteindre certains objectifs que nous
sommes fixés s'agissant du Ghana la
restructuration de la dette est en cours
donc j'ai bon espoir que comme pour la
Zambie comme pour le chat comme pour le
Sri Lanka nous puissions y parvenir vous
posez aussi une question essentielle qui
est la place respective de la Chine et
des pays occidentaux je pense que l'une
des singularités françaises et que l'on
doit aussi au président de la République
et à son action c'est d'avoir grâce au
Club de Paris garder un rôle absolument
majeur sur les restructurations de
dettes des pays en développement et nous
refusons d'avoir un autre cadre que
celui du Club de Paris et nous refusons
d'écarter la Chine nous estimons que
tout ambition de restructuration de la
dette qui mettrait la Chine de côté
comme certains de nos partenaires le
souhaitent serait une erreur politique
majeure nous n'avons aucune chance de
ressources culture et la dette si la
Chine n'est pas à bord donc le choix se
résume à mettre la Chine de côté avant
de confrontation entre le G7 et la Chine
sur les pays en développement je pense
que ce serait une faute politique que
nous perions très cher au 21e siècle ou
continuer comme nous le faisons à
associer la Chine je pense que les
progrès que nous avons enregistrés sont
bons signes je pense que la présence du
Premier ministre chinois à Paris pendant
deux jours est également un excellent
signal de notre capacité à faire bouger
les lignes s'agissons de la part de la
Commission européenne et de l'Union
européenne l'Union Européenne a une part
mineure en matière d'aide au
développement inférieur à 20% je vous
dis les choses très simplement je
souhaite que l'aide publique au
développement continue à rester une
compétence nationale les enjeux sont
trop importants pour que ce soit dilué à
une autre échelle
bien
c'est une réponse claire pour la France
insoumise c'est Monsieur Le Gall qui va
s'exprimer
si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le sommet pour le nouveau pacte
financier global a eu le mérite
d'exister
néanmoins je à titre personnel je
donnerais un bémol quand même sur en
évoquant la faible présence des
représentants au plus haut niveau du G7
on avait un seul chef d'État
quid notamment de la représentation des
USA dont on sait que alors qu'on sait
que le dollar reste la clé de voûte non
officielle mais la clé de voûte quand
même du système monétaire international
par ailleurs certaines questions
fondamentales nous semblent avoir été un
peu éludés
ou en tout cas très peu creusé comme
notamment la taxation des plus grandes
fortunes que soit au nord ou au sud
parce qu'il s'agit pas d'opposer le Nord
et le Sud en permanence il y a des
logiques quand même parfois parallèles
une vraie taxation sur les transactions
financières qui n'entraînent pas
d'investissement dans le système
productif il y en a des quantités
colossales
une vraie questionnement sur la
brutalité des hausses de taux d'intérêt
des banques centrales alors certes je
vous rejoins quand vous dites que la
Chine a une part majeure ou en tout cas
une part très importante dans les dettes
désormais des pays dit du Sud il n'en
reste pas moins que il y a quand même
encore un impact énorme des hausse
brutales de taux d'intérêt des banques
centrales européennes etatsuniennes sur
les l'explosion de la dette et de la
charge de la dette dans les pays d'IDI
du Sud donc est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
réfléchir au-delà de la question
climatique à des clauses de suspension
quand il y a des hausses brutales de
taux d'intérêt
qui peuvent avoir des effets désastreux
est-ce que vraiment vous avez vraiment
poussé en ce sens c'est ce qu'il y a de
vrais obstacles ou est-ce que la France
est encore à la moitié du gay sur ce sur
ce chemin enfin concernant l'aide
publique au développement
il
faire venir davantage d'argent privé
c'est finalement cacher les
investissements on est public au
développement et nous on n'a aucun
problème est-ce que nos entreprises
investissent dans le monde entier mais
ne faisons pas croire c'est du
gagnant-gagnant à chaque fois et ne
créant pas de malentendus comme il y en
a déjà beaucoup avec les peuples
concernés nous nous pensons qu'il faut
recalibrer l'aide publique au
développement davantage sur l'aide
d'urgence humanitaire quand elle est
nécessaire parce que aucun acteur privé
ne peut le faire à la place pour le coup
des états et à l'inverse
remodeler une politique internationale
notamment les accords de commerce avec
l'Afrique etc qui permettent un
développement endogènes sans faire
croire que ce sont des investissements
déguisés en aide publique au
développement qui changeront la donne et
pour que tout ça soit parfaitement
cohérent nous souhaiterions et je
voudrais avoir votre avis là-dessus en
tant que coachuteur savoir si on peut
donner plus une tutelle plus forte du
ministère d'affaires étrangères sur
l'AFD dont on sait qu'elle fonctionne un
petit peu de l'expression en roue libre
oui très bien monsieur le ministre qui
n'est pas des Affaires étrangères
non qui ne souhaite pas d'ailleurs
oui je pense c'est très bien avoir une
coûteuse et je ne suis pas du tout
favorable renforcement de la tutelle du
ministère de l'étranger sur l'AFD je
vous dis très sincèrement il y a
beaucoup d'argent en jeu donc je pense
que c'est bien que le mise des finances
s'assure que l'argent est bien employé
je ne changerai pas de position sur ce
sujet
sur la taxation sur les transactions
financières moi j'adore que nous fasse
la leçon sur le sujet je rappelle que
nous en avons une alors pour considérer
qu'elle est insuffisante elle est
partielle mais il y a beaucoup de pays
qui nous font halçon sur le sujet qui
n'ont pas de taxation sur les
transactions financières donc il
commence à mettre en place une taxation
sur transaction financière avant de nous
demander de faire davantage d'un autre
apport plus d'un milliard d'euros par an
on peut trouver que ça n'est pas
suffisant on peut trouver qu'il faut
faire plus qu'il faut l'améliorer je dis
simplement que ceux qui nous font la
chance sur ce sujet très souvent non pas
de taxation du même type
s'agissant de la taxation internationale
nous nous sommes pas du tout fermés sur
ce sujet
j'ai toujours indiqué le président de la
République également que nous refusions
une augmentation des impôts dans un pays
qui a le taux de prélèvement obligatoire
le plus élevé de tous les pays de CD et
là aussi les Français décideront mais
nous ne sommes pas prêts à changer de
position là-dessus en revanche qu'il y
ait un sujet aujourd'hui sur l'évasion
fiscale ou la capacité d'optimisation
fiscale de certaines très grandes
fortunes oui la question peut se poser
bien sûr ne l'évacue pas d'un revers de
la main est-ce que la solution nationale
certainement pas est-ce qu'il faut y
avoir doit y avoir une réflexion
internationale sur le sujet oui et nous
sommes prêts à voir cette réflexion au
niveau international sur ce type de
taxation qui permettrait de remettre de
la justice fiscale à la seule échelle
qui vaille quand on parle de grandes
fortunes ou de possibilités
d'optimisation c'est à dire l'échelle
internationale nous fonctionne pas fermé
à cette réflexion nous avons fermé la
porte des augmentations d'impôts
nationaux nous ne fermons pas la porte à
plus de justice à l'échelle
internationale je rappelle que vous
parlez à un responsable politique qui a
mis en place la taxation des gens du
numérique et nous avons été le premier
état au monde à le mettre en place en
affrontant la réaction de Monsieur Trump
à l'époque et nous avons poussé à une
taxation minimale à l'impôt sur les
sociétés donc nous sommes ouverts sur ce
sujet par ailleurs nous avons défendu
très clairement une taxation sur les
transports maritimes quand à la
représentation diplomatique
s'agissant du G7 je rappelle juste que
Monsieur Scholtz le chancelier allemand
a participé à cette réunion la
présidente de la Commission européenne
également les États-Unis étaient
représentés par la secrétaire américaine
au trésor et surtout nous avons eu des
participations de très haut niveau des
pays en développement je pense
évidemment au président Lula le Brésil
est un acteur absolument décisif dans
cette question du soutien en pays en
développement et un autre pays auquel
j'attache beaucoup d'importance parce
qu'il est confronté à des défis
considérables aujourd'hui et que il est
décisif dans la stratégie diplomatique
française c'est l'Egypte qui était
représentée par le président Sissi
je vous remercie maintenant c'est pour
les républicains c'est notre
vice-président monsieur Herbillon merci
beaucoup monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je vous remercie d'avoir
temporairement délaissé la commission
des finances vous êtes régulièrement
auditionné pour être présent aujourd'hui
devant notre commission des affaires
étrangères afin d'évoquer le bilan du
récent sommet de Paris pour un nouveau
pack financier mondial nous partageons
bien évidemment les objectifs de ce
sommet visant à dégager de nouvelles
ressources pour lutter contre la
pauvreté le réchauffement climatique et
des pays qui sont confrontés et en ce
sens ce sommet était bienvenu mais
néanmoins malgré une volonté certaine et
une communication abordante nous avons
quelques difficultés à cerner les
réelles avancées concrètes de ce sommet
peut-être dans votre réponse vous allez
nous éclairer davantage on a bien noté
les les mesures de 100 milliards de
dollars par an en faveur des en
développement pour financer leur action
de lutte contre le changement climatique
mais c'est de la mise en oeuvre de
l'engagement de Copenhague qui datait
d'il y a 14 ans nous avons bien observé
la confirmation l'engagement de 2021
pour la rééocation de 100 millions 100
milliards de dollars de droits de
terrasse spéciaux par le FMI et
l'introduction d'une clause de
suspension de la dette en cas de
catastrophe naturelle par la Banque
mondiale ainsi le président de la
République c'est félicités je cite d'un
consensus complet pour réformer en
profondeur le système financier mondial
tant mieux acceptons en l'augure mais on
a le sentiment qu'il n'y a pas assez de
concret et peu de mesures nouvelles pour
le moment tout comme l'instauration
d'une taxe carbone sur le transport
maritime au sujet de laquelle les
discussions doivent se poursuivre enfin
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
des accords ont été passé avec le
Sénégal pour accompagner ce pays dans sa
transition énergétique
et des accords ont été conclus avec la
Zambie et le Ghana notamment pour la
restructuration de la dette à ce sujet
vous je veux revenir sur la Chine que
vous avez évoqué vous avez souligné lors
d'un entretien RFI que la présence du
Premier ministre chinois était un geste
décisif je vous cite pour restructurer
les dettes notamment celle de la
zambique j'évoquais lien instant nous le
savons de nombreux entreprises chinoises
sont très présentes en Afrique pour
construire et exploiter exploiter les
projets financés par des prêts chinois
de la même manière Pékin dans le cas de
la renégociation de ses créances les
transforme parfois en prélèvement en
nature de matière première ou d'actifs
alors que les pays européens étaient peu
représentés lors du sommet je voudrais
savoir si vous regrettez ces absences et
si vous n'auriez pas préféré construire
une réponse européenne forte pour
endiguer l'influence chinoise sur le
continent africain je vous remercie
monsieur le vice-président
vous avez à peine débordé
monsieur le ministre
de
ne pas vous contredire au risque de me
répéter
je crois que la France la France a une
je souscris totalement à cette remarque
en ancienne enseignant que je suis
la France a une position spécifique avec
le Club de Paris
moi j'ai jamais été favorable aux idées
consistant à renoncer à nos avantages
diplomatiques essentiels comme la place
de l'ombre permanents au Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies où le fait
que nous dirigeons le Club de Paris
c'est le lieu de restructuration des
dettes mondiales nous avons intérêt à
ouvrir ce lieu on fait que ce nouveau
cadre commun à la Chine et à travailler
main dans la main avec elle plutôt que
de refermer le club et de vouloir le
faire dans un format européen un peu
évasif donc je crois que nous avons
intérêt à garder cette position
travailler avec nos partenaires
européens mais sans redéfinir le cadre
quant à la place de la Chine oui c'est
le premier prêteur mondial elle a une
place majeure sur le continent africain
et elle a pris comme habitude de prendre
comme garantie de ses prêts des
infrastructures des pays en question ce
qui lui permet ou voir parfois les
terres de ces pays en question
parfaitement conscients de ces enjeux là
notre choix stratégique est d'engager la
Chine plutôt que de nous y opposées
je vous remercie pour le groupe modem et
indépendant madame Gatel merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur le
Ministre d'être venu devant notre
commission pour faire le point à l'issue
d'un sommet pour un nouveau pacte
financier dont l'organisation était
extrêmement attendue et a été salué par
l'ensemble des observateurs et qui
finalement s'inscrit dans la dans la
logique de la trajectoire déployée par
le Président de la République depuis
2017 sur l'augmentation de l'aide
publique au développement alors ce
sommet qui a réuni une quarantaine de
chefs de chefs d'État et de gouvernement
aura été marqué d'ores et déjà par un
certain nombre d'avancés je veux les
rappeler les droits de tirage spéciaux
vous l'avez rappelé 100 milliards
d'euros de dollars pardon la mise en
place du fond pour la biodiversité la
restructuration de la dette de la Zambie
ou encore l'accord pour la transition
climatique du Sénégal dont nous avons eu
l'occasion de parler ce matin et puis
également l'opinion partagée sur la
nécessité de revoir
les institutions
issues de Bretton Woods pour faire face
aux nouveaux défis alors le la question
des nouveaux financements était
évidemment au cœur des discussions et ça
s'inscrit finalement dans une longue
tradition française puisque rappelons-le
la taxe sur les billets d'avion pour
financer United l'imposition minimale
pour les grandes entreprises portées par
la France et puis à l'OSCE puis au
niveau européen et puis la taxe sur les
transactions financières qui existent
d'ores et déjà dans notre pays alors
justement vous vous l'avez évoqué
rapidement
et ce qu'on est-ce que dans la poursuite
des conclusions du sommet ce sujet
particulier pourrait avancer à un plan
européen et puis sur sur le sujet de du
transform maritime qui fait aujourd'hui
figure d'exception dans la mesure où
c'est l'un des secteurs non taxés qui
subsistent est-ce que vous pouvez
dresser les perspectives sur la mise en
place d'une telle taxe car pour
reprendre les mots du président de la
Banque mondiale nous n'avons pas le luxe
du temps je vous remercie
merci madame la députée de Paris
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances peut-être pour faire un point
sur
les taxations existantes et celles sur
lesquelles nous sommes ouverts
je suis convaincu que la justice fiscale
passe par des décisions internationales
et qu'en revanche l'injustice fiscale
c'est augmenté les impôts en France
donc c'est là-dessus qu'il faut mettre
toute notre poids politique c'est
beaucoup plus difficile mais d'abord ça
rapporte beaucoup plus et c'est moins
pénalisant pour notre économie le
produit envisagé de l'impôt minimal à
l'impôt sur les sociétés à 15% et de
l'ordre de 2 milliards d'euros par an
c'est des sommes qui sont très
importantes et c'est un point de départ
et au moins ça ne fragilise pas la
compétitivité française par rapport à
ses voisins européens ou à ses voisins
mondiaux la taxation sur les géants du
numérique qui aujourd'hui est encore à
l'échelle nationale mais avec d'autres
pays qui s'en inspirent nous rapportent
de cette sens 750 millions d'euros par
an elle ne cesse de croître année après
année
toujours je souhaite taxation
internationales nous avons une taxe sur
les transactions financières qui est un
prélèvement de 0,3% du montant de
l'achat des titres des entreprises
françaises dans la capitalisation
boursière dépasse un milliard d'euros
les recettes de cette taxe sont
croissants vous avez indiqué plus de 1
milliard nous sommes en 2020 2021 2022 à
1,8 milliards d'euros donc c'est déjà un
prélèvement qui est extrêmement élevé
sans effet négatif sur la tractivité de
la place de Paris qui je le rappelle est
devenu la première place financière en
Europe ce qui est pas quelque chose duel
ou auquel on se serait attendu depuis
quelques décennies il y a des
propositions notamment d'inclure les
transactions ce qu'on appelle les
intradets dans l'assiette de la taxe ce
qui n'est ni souhaitable du point de vue
financier ni faisable en l'état du droit
et des infrastructures de marché donc je
pense que si déjà tous les pays de la
planète notamment les pays développés du
G7 accepter d'avoir le même dispositif
de taxes transactions financières que
celui que nous avons ce serait déjà une
grande avancée après ce transport
maritime aux éditions de CO2 nous y
sommes très favorables je pense que cela
peut avancer relativement rapidement
mais ça ne vaut le coup que si tout le
monde est à bord c'est qu'elle le dit
parce que le jour où il y a un seul État
qui n'est pas soumis à cette taxation
sur transport maritime il y a fort à
parier que tous les pavillons nationaux
vont s'installer dans cet état là qui
deviendra un paradis de la fiscalité
maritime donc il faut que tout le monde
soit à bord c'est compliqué mais je
pense que c'est jouable enfin le dernier
point c'est cette réflexion sur les plus
grandes fortunes et sur la situation
d'un certain nombre de personnes j'ai vu
qu'il y ait vu un appel de 200
millionnaires pour être davantage taxé
nous ne sommes pas fermés à cette idée
là là encore la solution doit être
internationale si on veut qu'elle soit
viable
et on a toujours un peu le sentiment
quand on lit ce genre d'appel d'assister
à manifester des dindes pour aller à
Noël
monsieur pour les socialistes apparentés
c'est monsieur le député de la Gironde
Monsieur David merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre
chers collègues
ce sommet qui avait pour but de mettre
en avant des actions concrètes en faveur
de la transition écologique se clôture
par un bilan mitigé néanmoins on peut
j'en conviens relever quelques points
positifs comme le fait que les pays du
Sud ont été forces de proposition et
leur voix apportées dans la continuité
de l'agenda de bridge turn
œuvre de la première ministre de la
Barbade pouvez-vous nous détailler
monsieur le ministre la feuille de route
des discussions au sein de
l'organisation internationale maritime
sur cette question d'une taxe maritime
qui pourrait être réalloué aux efforts
de lutte contre les changements
climatiques
pouvez-vous également nous faire part
des ambitions françaises pour le
prochain sommet sur le financement
climatique en Afrique
porté par le président du Kenya et pour
les assemblées de la Banque mondiale du
FMI qui porteront opportunément sur des
questions de dettes et de lever de fonds
pour les pays les plus pauvres je
souhaite également monsieur le ministre
profiter de votre présence pour vous
interroger sur un sujet connexe mais
préoccupant
en France 80% des interruptions de
grossesse assistée médicalement le son
par l'utilisation de pilules abortives
produite presque en totalité aux
États-Unis
or nous connaissons actuellement une
pénurie peut-être dû à la politique
anti-égé de certains états faisant
pression sur les laboratoires ma
question sera donc simple et directe
jusqu'à quand l'IVG en France dépendra
de la bonne volonté d’état américain et
une action de votre part est-elle
envisagée pour ramener en France la
production de ces pilules abortives
merci
je vous remercie monsieur le député
monsieur le ministre
voilà parfait
oui monsieur le député David donc sur
l'IVG je vous apporter une réponse
écrite parce que je n'ai pas la réponse
à votre question pour être très simple
même si nous avons engagé la
relocalisation avec le président de la
République d'un certain nombre de
médicaments et de principe actifs sur
cette question là je peux pas vous dire
de choses qui soient inexactes
s'agissant la taxe de transaction
maritime les travaux vont commencer dès
la semaine prochaine dans le cadre de
l'Organisation maritime internationale
je pense que nous pouvons avoir des
résultats relativement rapide sur ce
sujet comme nous l'avons obtenu sur le
transport aérien quand aux différentes
décisions prises dans le cadre de ce
sommet je rappelle que la première mise
à Barbade avec nous avons organisé ce
sommet était la première à reconnaître
que on pouvait au moins reconnaître au
présent de la République la
détermination à faire aboutir ce sujet
déjà arrivé à rassembler à Paris
plusieurs dizaines de chefs d'État dont
la moitié de chef d'État africain des
membres du G7 des membres du G20 et des
membres des briques qui arrivent à se
mettre d'accord sur le constat puis à
définir un calendrier puis à reconnaître
que la question des banques mondiales la
question des DTS la question du FMI la
question de l'engagement des acteurs
privés sont décisifs c'est déjà un très
beau résultat car honnêtement il y a
quelques années nous étions très loin
d'arriver à un consensus sur
l'utilisation des DTS ou sur le
fonctionnement de la Banque mondiale et
le nouveau président de la Banque
mondiale est extraordinairement
déterminée à progresser sur ce sujet
donc je pense que c'est très prometteur
pareil aux eviter à juste titre un
acteur majeur de ce sujet qui est le
président du Kenya que fasse nombre de
propositions aussi moi je pense que la
base le socle des gens mais posé que
nous avons réussi la France peut en être
fière à avoir posé la définition d'un
nouveau cadre de Bretton Woods plus
adapté aux pays en développement et
réchauffement climatique à nous
maintenant de le traduire en espèce
seulement des trébuchante et en décision
les plus concrètes possibles dans les
mois qui viennent
merci monsieur le ministre pour le
groupe des écologistes et apparentés
c'est Hubert Julien La Ferrière qui
prend la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre dans vos
propos intrigues vous n'avez pas résisté
à la tentation de lier l'aide publique
au développement avec la régulation des
flux migratoires à deux reprises
d'ailleurs dans dans vos propos je pense
et je ne suis pas le seul je pense que
c'est dangereux de faire ce lien et que
l'aide publique au développement doit se
cantonner aux trois objectifs que vous
avez d'ailleurs également rappelé la
lutte contre la grande pauvreté la lutte
contre les inégalités mondiales et la
préservation des des biens publics
mondiaux en particulier le climat et la
préservation du vivant je ne dis pas que
dans certains cas les projets des
développements vont pas décourager
évidemment l'aventure parce que des
populations vont retrouver le goût de
vivre sur leur territoire mais toutes
les études montrent que de toute façon
le développement ne
favorise pas la lutte contre les flux
migratoires bien au contraire le
développement encourage la mobilité et
si le développement encourage la
mobilité ce n'est pas l'aide publique au
développement qui heureusement
d'ailleurs ne contribue qu'en partie au
développement des pays qui va évidemment
décorer décourager les migrations que ce
soit en série en Afghanistan au Soudan
ou ailleurs donc je ne suis pas le seul
mais je crois qu'il y a un danger et
nous le rappellerons autant que ce sera
nécessaire de lier être public au
développement et flux migratoire
d'autant plus que le développement
encourage la mobilité et donc les flux
migratoires sur l'enjeu du sommet vous
avez bien sûr rappelé les enjeux et les
résultats
lorsque Esther Duflot est venu nous
donner les chiffres que vous nous avez
donnés elle nous a rappelé bien sûr et
nous l'avons dit avec elle que c'est une
tête écologique que nous avons à l'égard
des pays pauvres c'est une des
technologique parce que les milliards
qui devront être nécessaires pour
financer je parle des de l'adaptation au
changement climatique dans les pays
pauvres c'est d'adaptation elle est
nécessaire parce que nous avons pendant
deux siècles émis et pas les pays qui
doivent financer donc c'est même plus un
devoir de solidarité c'est en fait un
devoir de justice et pour répondre à ce
devoir de justice il y a besoin de
financement et c'est pour ça que moi
j'ai accueilli évidemment avec
enthousiasme en tout cas au moins les
perspectives que se donner le sommet
qu'il y a évidemment des enjeux
importants mais il y a des enjeux
importants aussi pour notre public au
développement et si j'ai toujours salué
évidemment le respect des engagements
financiers à savoir aujourd'hui nous
sommes à 0,656% de produits vous le
savez que notre loi du 4 août 21 a donné
l'objectif de 0,7% et que nous aimerions
savoir si vous pouvez nous dire
aujourd'hui si cet objectif de 0,7% sera
tenu je vous remercie
moi aussi je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre voulez-vous répondre à monsieur
le député du Rhône
alors sur le dernier point j'aurai
l'occasion
au moment de la présentation du projet
de loi de finance 2024 de vous donner
tous les chiffres sur
la part de la BD l'objectif chiffré que
nous nous sommes fixés avec le président
de la République
je redis simplement que la France a
maintenu un niveau d'aide publique au
développement extraordinaire
au regard des contraintes de finances
publiques qui pèsent sur notre pays et
avoir augmenté de 50% le budget de la
depuis 2017 c'est un effort
considérable de 10 à 15 milliards
d'euros
il y a pas beaucoup de budget
dans notre pays qui peuvent se targuer
d'avoir augmenté de 50% au cours des
cinq dernières années donc nous avons
fait les efforts nécessaires pour tenir
nos engagements et pour avoir une
mobilisation qui soit la plus forte
possible
deuxième élément ça a été écologique ça
je reconnais bien volontiers je pense
que c'est de toute façon le grand sujet
politique que nous présente les pays en
développement qui expliquent dans le
fond si aujourd'hui il y a une telle
difficulté climatique c'est parce que
vous avez émis de manière très brutale
depuis la fin du 19e siècle avec la
première la deuxième révolution
industrielle vous nous avez laissé une
dette écologique et maintenant vous nous
demandez de la payer à votre place la
réalité c'est que ils ont aussi un atout
ces pays c'est de pouvoir passer
directement à une économie décarbonée je
pense qu'un des grands enjeux c'est
d'amener les pays en développement le
plus vite possible va à l'économie
décarbonée que se rattrapage de se fasse
pas par la case carbone
ce serait un peu contradictoire de dire
en vous reproche la dette carbone que
vous avez laissée à la planète mais on
va l'alourdir avec notre propre dette
carbone je pense que la tranche de
collectif c'est de sortir de cette
logique là et dire on fait passer des
pays directement alors ça peut être de
l'hydrogène vert ça peut être avec des
panneaux solaires ça peut être avec
d'autres énergies renouvelables à une
économie développée et des carbonée
c'est ça pour moi le grand enjeu sinon
je pense qu'on commettra une erreur
majeure quant au lien entre flux
migratoire et être public au
développement nous ne créons pas de
conditionnement je le rappelle il y a
absolument aucune condition entre les
publics au développement et la maîtrise
des flux migratoires les objectifs vous
avez rappelé restent les objectifs de la
je continue pour ma part à penser
que notre intérêt d'avoir un
développement équilibré entre le Nord et
le Sud si nous voulons remédier à ces
risques de flux migratoires c'est pas la
même chose d'avoir des flux migratoires
venant de pays développés où il s'agit
de faire des échanges d'étudiants ou des
échanges de compétences et avoir une
partie des populations qui fuient leur
territoire parce qu'il n'y a aucune
perspective de développement économique
et une très grande pauvreté qui se
développe
je vous remercie je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
maintenant c'est à tour de Monsieur le
Député du Havre de parler au nom de la
Gauche démocrate et républicaine c'est
notre vice-président Jean-Paul Lecoq
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre heureux déjà que vous fassiez
une audition qui ne soit pas à huis clos
c'est pas toujours le cas ici
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que on
considère qu'on s'attaque pas vraiment
aux racines du mal concernant cette
cette réunion à propos du nouveau pacte
financier premier racine la fiscalité
internationale vous avez beaucoup
développé donc je vais pas vous reposer
la question mais il y a quand même la
question des taux des assiettes sur les
transactions financières par exemple de
la taxe sur les transactions financières
ensuite on aurait aussi préféré lire une
promesse de lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale aborder un peu le sujet ou
d'avancer sur la taxation internationale
sur les entreprises qui étaient promises
en juin 2021 quand même bon l'a pas trop
vu les choses je pense que quand même
vous avez une position dogmatique sur
l'augmentation des impôts y compris dans
notre pays l'impôt ces révolutionnaire
monsieur le ministre c'est quelque chose
de juste quand il est utilisé à bon
escient et la question c'est pas de
savoir combien on paye d'impôts c'est de
savoir quel service on a en face et il y
a bien des pays où la fiscalité est
élevée mais le service et la qualité de
vie est-elle que les gens ça les gênent
pas de payer des impôts et puis c'est
juste ça permet que ceux qui ont
beaucoup sont pas obligés de faire une
pétition pour dire en tant que
milliardaire qui doivent payer plus mais
ce sont taxés comme il le faut
le deuxième la deuxième racine du
problème c'est l'architecture financière
internationale stratagère générale à
l'occasion de cette réunion vous l'avez
entendu ce sera-t-elle générale des
Nations Unies a dit à l'occasion de se
sommet
devenu dépasser dysfonctionnel et
injuste faut entendre le scooter des
Nations Unies et donc il faut changer
les choses la question du droit de
tirage spéciaux tout le monde connaît à
peu près le fonctionnement c'est c'est
sa disqualifie les pays les plus pauvres
c'est à dire que plus terrible plus à
droite tirage spéciaux ce qui est un peu
absurde donc il faut il faut vraiment
qu'on change cette architecture vous
avez dit que ça allait se modifier mais
j'ai pas le sentiment que ça aille au
niveau où il faut
il reste une grande question quand même
par rapport à l'Afrique c'est c'est la
pseudo réforme du franc CFA elle évolue
par le Président de la République mon
groupe pense que c'est une insulte aux
nations qui compose la CEDEAO et vous
devriez stopper cette réforme et
reprendre depuis le début je crois qu'on
n'a pas encore compris que les peuples
d'Afrique veulent construire une autre
relation avec la France et être
eux-mêmes les maîtres de leur destin
voilà et puis parce que j'ai pas le
temps et parce que j'ai voulu être poli
avec vous
il y a la question des des traités de
libre-échange la façon dont ils sont
négociés et on pense que ça pose
vraiment le sujet
de l'exploitation des pays et donc voilà
que qu'en pensez-vous terminer avec ces
traités de livraison et faire en sorte
que les pays a une vraie fiscalité qui
leur permettent de se développer parce
que la fiscalité des pays les plus
pauvres est un élément très important
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
vice-président que vous pouvez
absolument être bien élevé car c'est
votre nature profonde et être dans les
temps c'est pour ça que j'ai pas dépassé
les trois minutes parce qu'après c'est
de l'insolence
je confirme que depuis près de 20 ans
que nous connaissons avec le
vice-président nos relations toujours
été courtoises et bien élevé donc pas
d'inquiétude de ce point de vue là
une petite carrière
je m'associe belles régions la Normande
reconnaissance de convivialité partagée
je quitte la Normandie à l'instant pour
rejoindre le franc CFA je rappelle juste
que nous avons engagé une réforme du
franc CFA que nous sommes la première
majorité à l'avoir fait nous avons gardé
un adossement sur l'euro pour des
raisons de stabilité mais nous restons
totalement ouvert à aller plus loin sur
la réforme du français F1 nous qui ne
porte plus ce nom je le rappelle nous
souhaitons simplement que ce soit les
pays des zones concernées qui en face la
demande et qui nous soumettent leur
proposition dans le respect justement de
la souveraineté de
mais moi je suis totalement ouvert le
président de la République également à
des évolutions plus fortes de ces zones
monétaires mais cette aux États de la
région d'en prendre la décision
s'agissant de l'architecture financière
internationale je partageons le constat
du Secrétaire général des Nations unies
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui nous a amené à
organiser ce sommet
nous avons tous réalloué 100 milliards
de dollars sur les 250 qui ont été émis
en 2021 ce droit de tirage spéciaux donc
c'est déjà une somme qui est
significative c'est 30% plus de 30% des
DTS qui ont été réalloués
avec la France qui a pris toute sa part
je rappelle que sur les DTS 17% sont
dans les mains des États-Unis donc la
décision américaine sera décisive si on
veut véritablement être efficace
s'agissons la taxation internationale
je pense que la France peut être fière
de son bilan en la matière je redis
qu'en 2017 c'est la France qui a porté
la taxation sur les géants du numérique
les fameux gafam nous l'avons fait
d'abord avec l'Italie l'Allemagne
l'Espagne l'Allemagne ensuite c'est
désolidarisé de cette proposition je
tiens quand même à le rappeler parce
qu'il y avait des risques nous avons
payé le prix de ces décisions avec des
sanctions américaines décidées par le
président Trump contre la France les
spécifiquement contre la France
notamment contre la viticulture
française donc nous avons payé le prix
fort de décision courageuse en matière
de taxation internationale et je pense
que personne ne peut nous faire de
leçons là-dessus jusqu'au aucun autre
état n'a accepté de payer ce prix là
donc de ce point de vue soyons fiers de
ce qui était accompli sur cette taxation
minimale à l'impôt sur les sociétés et
le progresse bien je pense qu'elle
pourrait être mise en œuvre très
prochainement et au niveau nationale
nous souhaitons qu'elle soit mise en
oeuvre dans les prochains mois et donc
nous ferons des propositions notamment
dans le cadre du PDF 2024 sur le sujet
enfin toujours sur l'architecture
financière internationale je partage ce
que vous avez dit sur les banques
mondiales de développement je pense que
nous avons une chance forte avec le
nouveau directeur général de la Banque
mondiale d'avoir enfin de véritables
changements dans l'architecture
financier international c'était moins le
cas avec son prédécesseur comme ne pas
en dire davantage
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
dernière
intervenante au titre des groupes c'est
pour le groupe yacht madame Estelle
Youssoupha qui est comme chacun sait
député de Mayotte
merci président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues au lieu de la réussite
du sommet pour le nouveau pacte
international financier tenu à Paris du
22 au 23 juin dernier il me semble
nécessaire de rappeler ici que des
territoires français ont eux aussi des
besoins urgents d'investissement et
d'infrastructures pour se développer je
pensais évidemment au territoire
ultramarins et à Mayotte que je
représente ici nous mahoresh et Mahorais
qui souffrent cruellement du manque
d'eau dans notre robinet somme stupéfait
de voir notre pays distribuer des
millions d'euros pour la production
d'eau potable alors qu'il n'arrive pas à
régler le sujet sur notre propre
territoire au-delà de ce triste constat
monsieur le ministre je souhaite parler
de coopération et attirer votre
attention sur le cas des Comores et de
la France les revendications des Comores
sur le territoire de Mayotte sont un
affront à notre histoire républicaine à
nos choix exprimés par les urnes
l'insulte des Comores au choix des morts
et d'être français ne doit pas rester
sans réponse monsieur le ministre est-il
possible de continuer à subventionner un
pays qui revendique ouvertement une
partie du territoire français vous avez
parlé de lier l'aide publique au
développement à la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine et la maîtrise
des flux figratoires
comment agir en cohérence avec cet
objectif et maintenir l'aide de la
France aux Comores je vous rappelle que
l'accord-cadre signé en 2019 prévoyait
150 millions d'euros d'aide au
développement aux Comores à cela
s'ajoute 104 millions d'euros d'aide
investis entre 2014 et 2018 qui ont fait
de la France le premier bailleur des
Comores un engagement a été pris à
Moroni pour lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine pour quel résultat un
déferlement migratoire qui tue Mayotte
une corruption cannibale et un
développement inexistant aux Comores des
engagements non tenus et une invitation
au président azali qui se permet
d'exprimer sans ambage dans les médias
français son discours contre Mayotte
contre notre pays monsieur le ministre
ma question est simple la France
va-t-elle encore soutenir et financer le
développement aux Comores qui revendique
ouvertement la souveraineté d'un
territoire de la République et qui de
surcroît ne respecte pas ses engagements
de lutte contre les flux migratoires je
vous remercie
je vous remercie madame le député de
Mayotte monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous apporter des apaissements
des apaisement je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas la question est parfaitement
légitime ce que je peux rappeler ce que
je veux rappeler de manière très claire
et sans aucune ambiguïté c'est que
Mayotte c'est la France que cela a été
décidé par la volonté historique des
Mahorais et que nous n'acceptons pas que
qui que ce soit notamment les Comores
puissent remettre en cause cette volonté
historique des habitants et des
habitants de Mayotte
qui remet en cause
allez en tout cas la nation française
est attachée à Mayotte et à son
territoire de Mayotte comme le son les
habitants et les habitants du territoire
j'entends parfaitement votre remarque
sur les Comores nous avons effectivement
je vous le confirme déployer une aide
très importante pour renforcer le ciel
de santé système éducatif et
perspectives professionnelles des
Comoriens cela doit se traduire par le
respect des engagements pris par les
Comoriens notamment en matière de
maîtrise des flux migratoires je le
redis j'entends parfaitement votre
revendication et la légitimité de votre
question
bien espérons que ça se traduira par des
résultats
maintenant c'est madame
vichnowski qui va
qui va exprimer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez déjà répondu à
beaucoup de questions une minute vous
m'avez dit
mais comme on a si vous faites une
minute trente ça ira
on est dans le temps alors c'est
pourquoi je ferai une observation et je
vous poserai deux questions très enfin
plus précises monsieur le ministre c'est
vrai vous avez raison c'est déjà un
succès de mettre en présence autant de
chefs d'État de société civile sur des
sujets aussi difficiles et de faire en
sorte qu'il se parle en faisant venir
des acteurs qui ne se rencontrent pas
toujours facilement et dans un cadre
c'est vrai informel mais qui peut
permettre à des discussions de s'engager
sur les questions concrètes
pouvez-vous nous dire pouvez-vous nous
préciser comment la gouvernance
du FMI et de la Banque mondiale par
exemple pourrait être
considérer au regard de la force de la
Chine
et sur cette fameuse taxation des
émissions de CO2
pour le transport maritime vous avez
raison il faut que il faut que tout le
monde soit à bord
20 pays ont soutenu cette proposition
pendant le sommet mais les États-Unis à
la Chine ont dit non de quel levier
dispose-t-on pour pouvoir les convaincre
je vous remercie
merci madame la députée du Puy-de-Dôme
alors sur la deuxième
question
l'union fait la force
les États-Unis refusaient
catégoriquement toute idée de taxation
des gens du numérique nous avons eu gain
de cause
on ne peut pas dire que la taxation
minimale à l'impôt sur une société pour
le coup elle existait aux États-Unis
donc là nous avions un soutien mais
emporter un enthousiasme délirant nous
avons finalement eugane cause mais il
faut être lucide tout état de création
internationales on met des très solides
mais prennent toujours beaucoup de temps
il m'a fallu cinq ans sur la taxation ce
genre numérique 6 ans soit taxation
minimale à l'impôt sur société je pense
qu'on peut aller plus vite sur le
transport maritime mais ça ne sert à
rien de s'engager là-dedans si les
États-Unis et Chine ne sont pas à bord
sachant que le plus grand port mondiaux
peuvent se trouver en partie aux
États-Unis et en Chine
sur le FMI sur Banque Mondial nous
souhaitons réviser les codes pas du FMI
d cette année nous avons engagé et
discussions sur la réforme des quotas
pour tenir compte des nouveaux
équilibres mondiaux il s'agissant de la
Banque mondiale la revue de la
gouvernance de la Banque mondiale est
prévue pour 2025 ce qui laisse environ
un an et demi de travaux pour revoir
cette gouvernance de manière générale il
faut bien voir que il y a dans le fond
deux grandes options géopolitiques
possibles la première c'est la réforme
des instances de Bretton Woods pour
avoir un cadre qui tienne compte des
nouveaux équilibre de force mondiaux et
de la question de la transition
climatique c'est le choix que nous avons
fait avec le président de la République
qui est celui d'une refonte d'une
refondation
et puis il y a l'autre option que celle
du Big Bang qui elle pour le coup est
dangereuse parce qu'elle aboutira à une
confrontation des institutions mondiales
dans lequel on verrait la Chine avec un
stand d'autre partenaires bâtir un autre
système
multilatéral à côté du système de
bretonne-out ça je pense que c'est très
dangereux et c'est ce que nous
expliquons d'ailleurs à nos partenaires
américains vous savez que nous avons des
nuances sur ce sujet nous estimons qu'il
faut engager la Chine comme lucides sur
les différences en matière de respect
des droits de l'homme et de systèmes
politiques nous sommes alliés des
États-Unis nous sommes partenaires de la
Chine ce n'est pas la même chose mais
pour autant nous pensons que
l'ostracisation de la Chine n'est pas la
bonne politique et qu'il vaut mieux
refonder lors de Bretton Woods que de
créer deux ordres différents qui
aboutiront inéluctablement à une
confrontation je poursuis encore plus ma
réflexion qui est fondée aussi sur des
éléments économiques et financier un des
grands enjeux du XXIe siècle c'est de
savoir si nous allons vers une
confrontation des deux premières
puissances mondiales ou si l'Europe
arrive à s'intercaler dans cette
confrontation pour créer un nouvel ordre
mondial d'équilibre entre la grande
puissance chinoise la grande puissance
américaine la grande puissance
européenne et le continent africain je
plaide fortement et vigoureusement pour
la deuxième option ça se traduit
d'ailleurs du point de vue économique
l'idée de découplage entre la Chine et
l'Europe entre la Chine et les
États-Unis tout simplement une absurdité
ça n'est ni possible ni souhaitable nous
produirions quasiment plus rien en
France il y avait un découplage complet
entre les économies françaises et les
économies chinoises les dépendances sont
déjà trop fortes que nous gagnons en
indépendance un certain nombre de biens
stratégiques les batteries électriques
les médicaments l'hydrogène oui bien
entendu mais qu'on aille vers un
découplage complet cela n'a aucun sens
je rappelle d'ailleurs que ceux qui se
font l'avocat de découplage aux
États-Unis notamment les républicains je
le rappelle que pendant la présidente de
Donald Trump le volume des échanges
commerciaux entre les Etats-Unis la
Chine a progressé donc c'est les mêmes
qui vous disent il faut séparer de la
Chine mais qui continue à faire du
commerce avec elle donc ne soyons pas
naïfs et continuons à plaider pour un
ordre multilatéral qui soit unique
plutôt que la confrontation de deux
blocs qui mènera à nouveau à des
conflits
bon voilà qui est très clair
maintenant pour le madame
Ray darbelote qui est
député de Polynésie française et qui
appartient au groupe GDR
je rigole c'était fou le président
monsieur le ministre en France les
communes les plus endettées sont les
premiers à subir les conséquences du
dérèglement climatique à la fois ces
territoires français sont ceux qui ont
l'empreinte carbone la plus faible de la
nation
avez-vous pensé monsieur le ministre
dans le grand livre du nouveau pacte
financier écrire un chapitre qui va plus
loin que les prêts à taux zéro du fond
vert pour les territoires d'outre-mer je
pense aux mécanisme de dette nature que
j'ai déjà évoqué avec Madame Duflot il y
a quelques jours merci
merci madame la députée
monsieur le ministre
je suis prêt à regarder évidemment
toutes les options possibles pour aider
ces territoires je rappelle juste que
nous avons ouvert une réflexion qui
rejoint vos propres réflexions sur les
mécanismes assurantiels pour les
territoires français qui sont les plus
touchés par les événements climatiques
ça me paraît absolument indispensable
c'est une prenons pas garde dans 15 ans
ou 20 ans je l'ai dit quand j'étais dans
les Antilles en Martinique et à la
Guadeloupe vous aurez demandé millions
de Français qui ne pourront pas
s'assurer et notamment nos compatriotes
et des départements des territoires
d'outre-mer qui sont les plus touchés
par les femelles climatiques les
assureurs disons désolé ça coûte trop
cher nous assurons des risques
n'assurant pas des certitudes
et comme malheureusement les événements
climatiques risquent de devenir des
certitudes on assure pas une voiture
dont on sait que le conducteur va avoir
un accident à peine il sera sorti de son
garage les assureurs on n'y prend pas
garde assureront plus des territoires
confrontés à 100 chances contre 100 les
phénomènes climatiques donc cette
question de l'assurance est devenue une
question majeure je vous invite à
participer aux travaux que j'ai lancé
sur le sujet mais vous vous
envisagez que la puissance publique
exerce une fonction de réassurance alors
ça peut être ça peut faire partie
effectivement des options la question la
rassurance est totalement décisive mais
en toute état de cause on peut pas
laisser des choses en l'état les Femen
climatiques sont trop diversement
répartis et malheureusement les
départements territoires d'outre-mer
sont les premiers touchés
merci Monsieur Viber
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre déjà m'excuser de mon retard
de n'avoir pu assister à votre
présentation mais
pour une bonne raison j'étais à la
session de mise en place de la
commission spéciale pour l'industrie
verte
une soirée à l'audition des ministres
tout à fait et je voulais justement vous
poser une question sur ce thématique là
bien évidemment puisque c'est un texte
ambitieux que votre sous votre patronage
on s'apprête à mettre en place et je
voulais savoir
dans quelle mesure ce texte industriel
pouvait répondre aux enjeux finalement
soulevés en matière de dérèglement
climatique
alors soyons clairs
l'industrie verte ne va pas porter de
réponse immédiate à la situation des
pays qui sont en situation d'extrême
vulnérabilité d'extrême pauvreté
en revanche
je crois qu'il y a deux phénomènes
structurants qu'il faut que nous ayons
tous présents à l'esprit
le premier c'est que nous assistons à
une restructuration des chaînes de
valeur mondialisation qu'on n'avons pas
connu depuis un demi-siècle
et pourquoi ce projet de loi me paraît
aussi important pourquoi est-ce que la
réindustrialisation est aussi importante
c'est que pour reprendre une expression
que j'ai employé de multiples reprises
nous sommes dans un Yalta industriel
nous sommes en train de répartir les
nouvelles capacités de production à
travers la planète et nous voulons
saisir cette opportunité pour
réindustrialiser le pays demain dans les
5 ans qui viennent nous aurons à travers
la planète redéfinis toutes les
capacités de production d'électricité
par les batteries électriques par
l'éolien par l'hydrogène vert pour
l'industrie automobile pour l'industrie
aéronautique il y a ceux qui auront fait
le nécessaire pour voir les usines et
les ouvriers chez eux et puis il y a
ceux qui l'auront pas fait et une fois
que le train est passé c'est fini
les capacités sont définies c'est fini
par ailleurs il y a un effet
d'attraction qui est très puissant nous
avons lancé les premiers nos gigafactory
de batterie électrique bah qu'est-ce qui
se passe notamment dans la région de
Dunkerque tout le monde veut dire
s'installer dans la région Dunkerque au
point que on manque de terrain
disponibles pour accueillir de nouvelles
giga Factory alors que d'autres pays ont
toujours pas une seule giga Factory donc
ça c'est le premier enjeu le deuxième
comme je le disais Monsieur Le Coq tout
à l'heure c'est comment est-ce que nous
permettons aux pays en développement de
passer directement d'un développement
carboné un développement décarboné et je
pense que c'est ça l'enjeu le plus
important c'est aider les pays qui sont
dans les situations économiques les plus
difficiles à ne pas passer par la case
économie carbonée
et c'est là que l'enjeu sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
de la sobriété les solutions
technologiques et clés sinon si c'est
pour développer des usines à charbon
partout à travers les pays en
développement ça n'aura pas grand
intérêt ni pour eux ni pour la planète
je profite de votre question pour
répondre à plus abortive ce que j'ai eu
la réponse qui m'a été donnée donc je
reconnais qu'il ait eu des tensions de
l'ordre de 10 à 20% en avril j'avais
pilule abortives il n'y a pas eu de
déficit de prise en charge
IVG nous avons désormais des stocks de 2
à 3 mois et depuis le 27 avril 2023 il
n'y a plus de tension avérées sur les
pays de la portée
ça c'est l'avantage d'avoir une
administration puissante et réactive en
cours de débat on a les éléments de
réponse oui madame carrois c'est
à vous
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation et d'être revenu sur le
sommet pour un nouveau pacte financier
mondial beaucoup a déjà été dit je ne
reviendrai très brièvement que sur trois
points le premier c'est la taxe au
niveau international sur les entreprises
de transport maritime je vais pas
reposer les questions qui ont été posées
mais c'était essentiel que nous
puissions travailler sur ce sujet 80% du
transport des marchandises se fait par
cette voix 3% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre aujourd'hui
des négociations vont avoir lieu le mois
prochain quel est concrètement la
position de la France qui sera taxée
comment comment ces fonds seront-ils
réalloués parmi les pays juste quelques
petits éléments peut-être de précision
sur notre position bien entendu ensuite
un autre sujet qui a été évoqué lors du
sommet mais de manière peut-être
moins importante était la nécessité de
réguler ou de revoir le rôle des agences
de notation ça a été évoqué dans une
table ronde il y a déjà eu de la
régulation en 2008 c'était la crise
financière mais principales agences de
notation bouddhistes
continuent à dominer le marché et avoir
un impact colossal sur les pays
lorsqu'il y a quelques petites
variations dans la notation et enfin
l'implication du secteur privé parce que
c'est un sujet qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur quelle piste en
France pour impliquer encore davantage
le secteur privé dans la transition
écologique alors peut-être parlerez-vous
de du projet de loi mais aussi pour
mobiliser l'épargne des Français dans ce
secteur merci beaucoup
du secteur privé on y reviendra dans le
cadre de la loi industrie verte mais
c'est effectivement un enjeu majeur et
j'aurais l'occasion lundi prochain avec
l'euro député Pascal Camphin de
présenter nos pistes sur le financement
de la transition climatique et je suis
convaincu que la mobilisation d'épargne
privée le recours profit d'un seront
privé et plus prometteur que
l'augmentation des impôts sur les agents
dotation on va tout l'objectif de la
clause climat justement c'est de réduire
la vulnérabilité des pays les plus
fragiles à l'égard de ces agences de
notation
d'un côté j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
à plusieurs reprises il faut pas non
plus accuser le thermomètre et faire
attention c'est en notation elles sont
là pour simplement évaluer la solidité
des finances publiques et la solidité de
la dette ça concerne des pays en
situation d'extrême pauvreté en
développement ça concerne aussi en
aperçu de il y a quelques semaines
enfin sur les taxes sur le transport
maritime je pense qu'il y a un point de
précision très important c'est que c'est
une taxe sur les émissions de CO2 du
transport maritime ça n'est pas une taxe
sur le fret maritime tout simplement
c'est une taxe maritime sera la fois
injuste et inefficace il y a beaucoup
d'autres transports maritimes que
simplement le transport de container
vous pouvez avoir des ferries vous
pouvez avoir des bateaux privés donc il
y a aucune raison que ce ne soit pas une
taxe globale sur les émissions de CO2
ça mérite d'être global c'est le mérite
d'être neutre et ça le mérite d'être
plus juste et plus efficace
par rapport à la fiscalité le
développement d'une fiscalité mondiale
c'était quelque chose de très éclairant
et qui introduisait une voie
relativement nouvelle dans ce débat ou
moins d'impôts plus d'impôts etc qui est
à débat convenu et assez stérile donc je
pense que nous allons apporter beaucoup
de choses je voudrais cependant vous
posez une question
on a un peu le sentiment que le GIEC a
tout à fait raison moi je ne suis pas du
tout climato-sceptique je crois que le
réchauffement climatique est une réalité
et que les causes la l'humanité les
activités humaines sont une cause
essentielle de se réchauffement
climatique peut-être pas exclusive mais
essentiel mais il y a deux choses qui
que je trouve très frappant en ce moment
premièrement c'est qu'on a l'impression
que le le réchauffement climatique
frappe inégalement
les parties du territoire mondial et que
ça appelle cette inégalité de dire que
nous sommes plutôt mal placé point de
vue là nous dans un pays comme la France
et que ça appelle quand même peut-être
une réflexion un petit peu différenciée
sur la façon qu'on avait dit bon c'est
les gaz à effet de serre ça part de
partout et ça retombe universellement
sur tout le monde alors ça paraît un peu
plus compliqué deuxièmement quel que
soit les les schémas on voit bien qu'il
y a pas mal de différences entre ce
qu'on promet et ce que ce à quoi les
états s'engagent est-ce qu'on va
finalement réaliser et on sait bien
qu'il n'y aura pas on va pas atteindre
je suis prudent les objectifs maximaux
qu'on se qu'on souhaiterait atteindre et
donc on va devoir faire face aux
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
qui seront de toute manière plus ou
moins importante mais que nous
éliminerons pas totalement et est-ce que
dans les les
perspective du sommet que nous avons eu
la semaine dernière et des
développements qu'il peut avoir
ces deux notions qui appellent je crois
des actions peut-être un peu différentes
de celles qu'on a jusqu'à présent
l'entreprise complémentaire n'est pas du
tout contradictoire est-ce que ces deux
notions vous paraissent pouvoir et
devoir être prise en compte
la réponse est oui
et je pense que le l'un des métromos
c'est l'adaptation qu'il s'agit pas
uniquement de lutter contre
réchauffement climatique qui est
indispensable il faut aussi une
adaptation au réchauffement climatique
qui est une réalité prenez des
propositions qui nous concernent tous
qui sont faites sur la ville de Paris
sur les toitures sur la végétalisation
sur ce sont des nécessités quel que soit
les efforts que nous fassions dans les
années qui viennent de toute façon le
réchauffement il est déjà là donc il y a
une part d'adaptation qui est nécessaire
qui doit se combiner à des changements
radicaux de modèles économiques même
chose pour les états il y a
effectivement des États qui sont
beaucoup plus touchés que d'autres des
parties du territoire qui sont beaucoup
plus touchés que d'autres les Antilles
pour reprendre l'exemple que j'ai donné
sont touchés maintenant régulièrement
par des cyclones qui dévastent les
habitations qui posent des problèmes
majeurs aux populations sur place donc
c'est bien cela qui justifie que il y
ait cette clause climat dans la dette
des pays les plus pauvres et que nous
regardions qu'il y ait des aides qui
soient différenciées d'un territoire à
l'eau ça justifie également cette
transformation de la en tenant compte
davantage de la situation climatique de
chaque étape quelque chose de tout à
fait nouveau puisque ça n'a jamais
existé auparavant donc je partage
totalement cette approche je profite de
votre dernière question monsieur le
Président pour vous remercier de la
qualité de vos questions et de la
sérénité qui a présidé au débat qui
n'est pas courant dans toutes les autres
commissions auxquelles j'ai la chance de
participer
nous acceptons le compliment cette cette
commission madame madame
Rabeau m'avait dit il y a quelques il y
a quelques temps dans l'ancienne
législature pareil que la commission des
affaires étrangères est un petit paradis
je lui avais répondu soyez heureux donc
l'ange et rejoignez-nous mais je crois
ici effectivement que nous avons des
habitudes de travail en commun qui sont
très agréables et que nous voulons
absolument préserver la fureur des
passions doit s'arrêter à la porte de
cette commission même si la vigueur des
convictions doit s'y exprimer merci en
tout cas monsieur le ministre de cette
visite parmi nous qui j'espère sera
suivi de quelques autres régulièrement
sans vouloir peser trop lourdement sur
votre emploi du temps vous êtes ici chez
vous vous avez beaucoup de choses à nous
dire nous avons beaucoup de questions à
vous poser et nous avons beaucoup à
entendre de vous merci en tout cas